alrighty i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message today
is october 20th 2021 and if you would
like to live chat
throughout the show if you want to talk
to other viewers if you want to
communicate with ruben report team
members in live chat you will have an
ability to get them messages and
questions live to me
during the show you can go to
report.locals.com or download the locals
ios or android app join the reuben
report community it's absolutely free to
join you got to pay a couple bucks if
you want to play along
and i think you'll dig it okay that's
what i'm saying before i get to the show
i just want to tell you that i just got
some great news and i think there's
going to be some particularly great news
to share let's say on friday i'm working
on it on friday but just make note put a
little pin
in your head that dave rubin said
something good's happening great news
lots cooking we're going to save the
world he said it today october 20th
2021. uh we got four stories for you i
know you guys love the gen saki stories
i like them too because the woman is
just a complete and utter ridiculous
buffoon and it's like oh my god am i
watching reality or is this just like a
bad 80s comedy with this woman she
cannot say anything true she is the
reverse
jim carrey from liar lie i remember liar
liar i would argue jim carrey's best
movie and of course jim carrey yes he's
gone off the deep end and he's sort of a
lefty whack job but in liar liar jim
carrey cannot tell a lie jenn saki is
basically the reverse jim carrey the
woman cannot say anything truthful and
even when she can kind of get close she
just can't finish it it's just quite
extraordinary so we got a little bit of
video from her
then we talked about this yesterday and
over the last week or so there is some
pushback on the vaccine mandate not
because people are right-wing racist
conspiracy theory maniacs but because
they want personal choice and in chicago
about 3 000 police officers
are protesting that's about a third of
all of the police officers in chicago
and believe me they need police officers
in chicago because uh there are all
sorts of murders every weekend in
chicago let's get the numbers on that
for a little later in the show when we
do the story we'll check how many people
have been killed in chicago this weekend
we're not allowed to talk about it
though because the race thing doesn't
fit the computer simulation that they
want us to only talk about uh so we're
gonna talk about some vaccine mandate
pushback stuff and there's really some
some nice stuff happening on the ground
third story i just thought this was sort
of culturally interesting you know i
know a lot of you saw the the dave
chappelle special on netflix and what
happened was you know he made a couple
comments
about trans people basically saying hey
i got no problem with trans people but
you know boys have penises girls have
vaginas five years ago that was pretty
standard stuff
but some netflix employees are now
protesting there's actually a protest
going on right this second outside
netflix headquarters originally
the netflix co-ceo said we're back in
chappelle this is his art he's allowed
to say what he wants now he just
basically backtracked the entire thing
and uh and it's quite ridiculous it's
like man you people always bow to these
hysterical lunatics so we'll dive into
that and then finally the sports story i
saw this yesterday this incredible video
that someone put together on the twitter
machine uh basically all of the news
shows that you're watching if you're
watching corporate news they are
basically all
brought to you by
yeah you guessed it pfizer
pfizer the company making one of the
shots that they are demanding everyone
putting their arm they're also
sponsoring all the news where the people
tell you that you have to get the shot
you think that's weird we got a
compilation for you but before we do
that story let's start with miss
jen
saki uh so uh what's the ducey's first
name is peter ducey it is peter ducey
right so peter ducey over at fox he is
basically the one kind of all-star
that's sitting in all these white house
press briefings right now he usually
sits right up front and he's the one
that's really pushing jen saki on all of
her nonsense and you know we've played a
gajillion clips of it and you can just
search reuben report jen saki it's just
like a hilarious compilation of this
ridiculous woman who's just so obviously
a liar and the way she enunciates things
as if she's a second grade teacher
really just terrible anyway we got two
pieces of video from her uh from
yesterday so first ducey's asking her
about all these immigrants coming in and
why are we having these immigrants come
in over and transport them throughout
the country in the middle of the night
and listen to her little twist of truth
why is the administration flying
thousands of migrants from the border to
florida and new york in the middle of
the night
uh well i'm not sure that's in the
middle of the night but let me tell you
what's happening here um
it is our 4 29 a.m well very early in
the morning here we are talking about
early flights earlier than you might
like to take a flight it is our legal
responsibility to safely care for
unaccompanied children until they
swiftly can be swiftly unified with a
parent or a vetted sponsor and that's
something we take seriously we have a
moral a right obligation to come to do
that deliver on that as a part of the
unification process our office of
refugee resettlement facilitates travel
for children in its custody to their
families or sponsors across the country
country so in recent weeks uh
unaccompanied children pass through the
westchester airport which i think is
what you're referring to and route to
their final destination to be unified
with their parents or vetted sponsor
it's no surprise that kids can be seen
traveling through states not just new
york it's something that we're also
working to unite children with their
family members or vetted sponsors in
other parts of the country as well
oh a lot of nonsense jen first off he
says why are we doing this in the middle
of the night the implication being that
obviously the government doesn't want
people to see this right they don't want
to send all of these unaccompanied
minors and all of these migrants just on
planes during the middle of the day when
there would be a lot of people taking
video and you know it's bright out and
people can see all these people often
not wearing masks and do they have any
american values do they care about
freedom et cetera et cetera so we're
going to do it overnight she gets him
she says oh it's 2 30 a.m oh no you know
she's saying well we're not doing it
overnight and uh you heard ducey say
well 2 30 a.m uh 4 29 and she implies
that that's early in the day i mean i'm
pretty sure if you got woke up at 4 29
a.m you'd say that's the middle of night
obviously that's just nonsense out of
her the bigger issue there is did you
catch what she's saying we have a
refugee resettlement program now i don't
know exactly and we can have an honest
debate perhaps one day about how many
people should come in what we need to do
with the border and all those things but
as i keep saying we're in the middle of
this pandemic that they keep telling us
is getting worse and worse and worse
even though we know that they're lying
about absolutely everything and that
they don't follow any of their rules and
all that good stuff and that trump was
trying to close the border and they've
opened the border and blah blah blah but
does it seem like the right time in
america to have a refugee resettlement
program and that we're sending sending
unaccompanied minors
uh that come across the border that
means they come across the border and
then we fly them to different places to
be with their family now most likely
it's not their parents if they're
unaccompanied minors maybe it's a
grandparent or an uncle or something or
i think she said something about their
sponsors so that these are people who
have been vetted and then they're saying
we want to take these children like is
that really what we should be doing in
america right now but everything that
they say they it all sounds we're nice
we let people in we're not like mean
donald trump who wanted a wall we let
people in and don't worry they we've
sure we've been keeping them in cages
but thanks to the media we don't call
them cages anymore now they're you know
big spectacular four seasons like rooms
um and then you know sure they're not
socially distancing not coming in with
masks then we just send them all over
the country in the middle of the night
because we're good people you understand
it's it's that orange man and all those
mean republicans who want us to have a
border and who want people to have
identification and who want to make sure
that people perhaps uh share some of the
same values or think that america is
decent or some of that stuff those are
the bad guys we're good because we say
all these things so that's just the
first part of the nonsense and then
listen to how flip she was i mean this
is really like when you want to just see
like what type of person jen saki really
is and i don't like attacking people but
like she's up there every day she's
putting herself out there to lie every
day to smugly dismiss all the concerns
of virtually every sane american and
listen to the flippant response when
she's asked about the supply chain stuff
just a question on the timing uh on the
supply chain issue yeah
actions that the president has taken
it was clear in march of 2020 when cobit
hit that the supply chains across the
world had been disrupted
even as as the sort of work to fight
back against kobe proceeded people it
was it was crystal clear that things
were not improving on supply chain
people couldn't get dishwashers and
furniture and treadmills delivered on
time not to mention all sorts of other
things so why the tragedy of the short
the treadmill that's delayed the trip
the tragedy of the treadmill that's
delayed lady you know what in america
for the last 50 years if you ordered a
treadmill you could get a treadmill it's
your buffoonish boss and these
ridiculous people like yourself who he
has hired that are making it harder to
get a treadmill so you're right it's not
the biggest issue if it takes three
months to get a treadmill but it is
indicative of a bigger problem that you
people are all incompetent and we have a
transportation secretary who is not
qualified to be transportation secretary
but who was hired because he was gay we
have a four-star
uh what is what is she now what is uh
for she's a four-star what now
trans education health secretary because
she's trans and now the the
so stupid
they're calling her trans and female
she's the first four-star health
secretary and she's the first female
health secretary like that's what the
surgeon general actually tweeted out
that she's the first female and she's
the first trans it's like pick one
congratulations females by the way
a man was the first one to take the jobs
pretty spectacular um so oh from locals
this is a good comment this is what i
want to do i want to be able to hear you
guys during the show thomas says how
about they resettle at martha's vineyard
yeah that's right that's the thing when
they resettle all of these people you
know they don't end up in brentwood and
in beverly hills they don't end up at
martha's vineyard they don't end up in
the hamptons right like why do you think
that might be but anyway the way she's
so flip about it the way she's just like
oh yeah you you people can't get your
treadmills it's like well you know
people are also noticing that their gas
prices are going up people are noticing
that when you go to the supermarket that
chicken
i literally went to the supermarket the
other day and i very as i always tell
you i very rarely go out but i went to
the supermarket and here in la
a
package
of organic chicken thighs was 12.99
12.99 a pound okay that's usually like
6.99 in la and probably in most of the
country you could get organic diets for
about 4.99 the prices of everything are
going up our ability to order something
and get it in a timely matter is going
up and she's she's so careless about it
and it's like again i hate to bring up
orange man but you know at the height of
the pandemic when everyone was freaking
out remember we were wearing gloves to
go outside and we had masks on our head
and we wrapped our heads in saran wrap
and tin foil and the rest of it
why didn't we have massive supply chain
issues meaning we did have there were
some delays on getting paper towel there
were some delays on getting toilet paper
some things like that but you could
still get all the products in a timely
manner it's only
since joe biden took over and his
incompetent yet diverse
crew clown car uh of of lackeys
basically that he's got behind him so i
don't i just i don't like jan saki did i
does my you feel good about this my
feelings were clear about this today i
don't like her very oh
connor gave me one of these so
guys let's talk about start mail you
know free email services like gmail and
yahoo aren't really free you pay with
your privacy internet giants bank on
exploiting your data by selling it to
the highest bidder your business plan
google has it your medical records yahoo
can sell them to drug companies
personally i don't want to open myself
up to identity theft and i can't imagine
you do either that's why i suggest using
start mail it makes me
it makes the email feel safe again and
start mail keeps your email private
period when you delete an email in start
mail it's gone forever and start mail
uses their own servers not amazon's
which means they can't be put out of
business like parlor switching to start
mail is seamless as well you can easily
transfer all of your current email data
so there's no starting from scratch you
get unlimited anonymous aliases this
feature protects your main email address
from spam and phishing attacks so that
people can't sell your info and they can
be deleted at any time i keep saying the
way forward is to build competitive
businesses that support our privacy
values which is why i value the service
start mail provides your cyber security
has never been more at risk take control
of your privacy with start mail before
it's too late start securing your email
privacy with start mail sign up today
and you'll get fifty percent off your
first year go to start mail dot com
slash ruben that's start with the t
s-t-a-r-t mail.com ruben for fifty
percent off your first year start
mail.com reuben and now back to me all
right so there is a pushback against
vaccine mandates and it is a beautiful
thing people
human beings free citizens in these
united states of america are saying i
want to make decisions for myself i
don't want the government and a bunch of
unaccountable bureaucrats to tell me
what i have to do with my life my
privacy my medical records and my
medical history is my business and my
doctor's business this is all good stuff
and we've seen a pushback from southwest
airlines employees we've seen a push
back from uh from now from in and out
which we'll get to in just a sec and a
huge push back now from chicago cops
over 3
000 of them
are now pushing back against lori
lightfoot's vaccine mandate got about a
minute it's worth the video for you
at least two memos have gone out since
friday's deadline but this morning the
head of the police union says officers
are holding the line the unofficial
number we have is about over 3 200 so
about a third of the department fop
president john continzara says that's
the number of officers who haven't
complied with the city's order to report
their vaccination status to an online
portal he says those officers will be
getting called in today and once again
they'll be asked to do so if they refuse
it sounds like they're going to go into
a no-pay status effective immediately
kanzar says this is no longer about the
vaccine or personal beliefs but about
collective bargaining rights all of
those things are a change in your
employment
policies you have to negotiate with us
what that looks like the city has
refused to do that two memos have been
sent out since friday the latest from
sunday involves consequences officers
could face if they don't follow the city
of chicago's vaccination policy that
officer will become a subject of a
disciplinary investigation that could
quote results in a penalty up to and
including separation from the chicago
police department the memo goes on to
say that sworn members of the department
who retire while under an investigation
may be denied retirement credentials on
saturday a different memo was sent out
it says days off now require approval
from a deputy chief or above cpd hasn't
said if this is related to the ongoing
tension between the police union and
mayor lori lightfoot over the city's
vaccine mandate but as of now the union
is not budging
our moniker all week has been hold the
line for a reason
hold the line that's right whether
you're in a union or whether you're an
individual trying to make some decisions
for yourself there's so much interesting
stuff there now of course already you
get my feelings on vaccine mandates okay
fine now i get it that the police are
part of the government they're not part
of the federal government in this case
they're part of the chicago the city
government
potentially the state government of
illinois
but these people are trying to make a
statement for themselves now what's
really interesting about this is what uh
the representative talks about there
that this affects their collective
bargaining so they go in and they
negotiate their contracts and
retirements and salaries and benefits
and all of these things and now the
state in essence is just trying to
change that right in front of them and
you heard that this could affect their
retirement they could take days off from
them suspend them you know take away pay
all sorts of stuff so i just want to be
very clear i stand a hundred percent uh
with these officers in chicago and by
the way
chicago does need officers if you think
for a moment that chicago can afford to
lose about 3 200 3 200 police officers
out of about 9 000 roughly a third of
them well they can't there were three
people killed in chicago this weekend 41
wounded in shootings across chicago
we've got a graphic that will play next
time we've been working on a graphic for
chicago shootings we just haven't
covered it in a while this flew at us at
the last second but the point is these
people need more police not less police
and yes you know everywhere they cut
police bad things happen less police
more crime that's how it works logic
reason yippity-dippity-do uh it's just
bananas so i stand with those people and
again this is how we will fight back
don't think that even donald trump or
some other republican you love or or
even ron desantis ron desantis because
he's a governor right now he's
intimately involved in this and he's
doing an incredible job in florida
making sure that these mandates won't
stick and making sure people have choice
but even ron desantis can't save you if
you live in florida it still will come
down to you and how you will live your
life and what you will do at your place
of business and where you work and all
of those things
and to that point speaking of places
that could use some more policing in san
francisco a local in and out franchise
is fighting the power they're not going
to vaccinate their people can you
believe it we've got some info here from
fox news
the city of san francisco temporarily
closed an in and out fast food
restaurant over the company's refusal to
force customers to prove that they are
vaccinated against the coronavirus we
refuse to become the vaccination police
for any government whenzinger declared
slamming the san francisco department of
health's requirements as unreasonable
invasive and unsafe and accusing the
city of asking restaurants to segregate
customers based on vaccine documentation
we fiercely disagree with it with any
government dictate that forces a private
company to discriminate against
customers who choose to patronize their
business the statement said this is
clear governmental overreach and is
intrusive improper and offensive the
store has since reopened but indoor
dining is not available so as far as i
know oh so it not a franchise okay so
i'm getting some info i like this i like
getting info on the fly so in and out
are not franchised they are all owned by
the parent in and out company
uh still operated still owned and
operated by the snyder family so that's
pretty fantastic i actually thought they
were a franchise so that's really
interesting so normally when it's a
franchise it's like you're licensing the
in and out logo and all the stuff
but you own it this is all owned by one
family so god bless these people they're
saying hey this is government overreach
it's not our job to do i suspect that
they're not forcing their employees to
be vaccinated but making some decisions
for themselves and by the way once you
make that decision as a as a
as a business especially
a fast food joint where people are
coming and going a lot it's like people
then can make the choice oh i don't want
to go there or i do want to go there
because they're in line with my values
or
i'm afraid of going there because i'll
die you might make these choices so
that's the beauty of what freedom is and
yeah it's a little messy but it's a hell
of a lot better than the alternative so
that is that is pretty spectacular i
will add one other thing about uh this
in and out situation which is that just
this morning uh lauren chen who's a
friend of the reuben report and a friend
of mine she uh tweeted out a image
outside of a chick-fil-a which basically
said i'm not sure the location
but basically said we welcome you
whether you're vaccinated or not whether
you're wearing a mask or not we don't
discriminate you know we're here to sell
chicken sandwiches that was the essence
of it you're not going to believe it the
chicken people want to sell chicken
sandwiches so in honor of chick-fil-a
which is a franchise by the way so that
one may have come from that specific
location and not top-down chick-fil-a
headquarters where they send the chicken
messages to the stores uh but
whether it was an la location or not i'm
making an announcement right now
we're having chick-fil-a for lunch you
want the chick-fil-a he wants the chick
but you want the chick-fil-a all right
we're having chick-fil-a
as many sauces let's name some sauces
you got the honey mustard you got the
polynesian you got the barbecue the what
the zesty buffalo you got the standard
uh in and out sauce anything else
anything else
ranch that's right ranch we're gonna get
all the sauces people and i will post a
picture at
reubenreport.locals.com uh this is funny
uh at clickaholic and local says
hopefully this entire administration
will be in and out
that's how you close the segment uh all
right part three here uh
netflix now you understand this this
netflix thing back in the day you'd have
to watch a channel and sometimes
something you wanted to watch came on
and there would be commercials and
everything well netflix came in and
cleaned a lot of that up you pay monthly
they give you a lot of stuff it's a ton
of crap but there's some stuff you want
on there and you pay for it i'm watching
squid game right now pretty good and i
like seinfeld repeats so there we are uh
well
netflix aired this special from dave
chappelle it was one of i believe it was
the last in like a six stand up uh
series that they did with chappelle it
was worth a ton of money and you're not
gonna believe this but occasionally guys
comedians say offensive things
occasionally when you're trying to say
something true but couching it in humor
so that people don't attack you you
might get close to the line of what's
acceptable and that might upset some
people and what might even happen is
that you might trip over the line and
say something genuinely offensive and
you know what life still goes on this is
how humans have interacted with each
other
since the beginning of time what did the
court jester do with the king right like
he would make fun of the king to make
everybody kind of feel okay with what
was going on there and yeah every now
and again the guy would fall over the
line probably got axed but now netflix
is trying to ask dave chappelle it's
absolutely ridiculous so we've got some
info here from the wall street journal
netflix co-chief executive officer ted
sarandos said he screwed up his efforts
to communicate with employees who were
upset over the closer a recent comedy
special by dave chappelle in which he
made remarks that some viewed as
offensive to the transgender community
in emails to netflix staff about the
special's debut earlier this month mr
cyrenos defended the closer citing its
popularity on the platform and the
company's commitment to creative freedom
he also said that the company believed
content on the screen doesn't directly
translate to real world harm in the
closer which was released earlier this
month and is currently among the most
watched programs on the service in the
u.s mr chappelle said gender is a fact
and said he identified as a turf an
acronym that stands for
trans-exclusionary radical feminists he
also compared the transgender community
to people who wear blackface what i
should have led with in those emails was
humanity mr sarendo said in an interview
tuesday evening i should have recognized
the fact that a group of our employees
was really hurting mr sarendo said his
remarks on content not causing real
world harm was also an
oversimplification
and lacking in humanity all right mr
co-ceo of netflix you're a clown and a
buffoon and now that you have apologized
after you did the right thing which was
defend artistic freedom and dave chabel
you will live on your knees forever so i
don't care how many hundreds of millions
of dollars you have i don't care how
influential you think you are i don't
care how much power you have over the
programming that gets out to the world
and how that affects us culturally you
you are in essence now a slave you are a
slave to a group of people who will
never let you stand up again so
congratulations to you by the way he's
co-ceo as i noted there his co-ceo the
other guy is reed hastings and you might
remember the name reed hastings because
i would talk often about reid hastings
at the beginning of september because
reed hastings
was the guy that was pouring millions
and millions of dollars into ads in
california that were backing gavin
newsom and lying about larry elder
calling him a trump clone and basically
a white supremacist and he wanted to
kill kids because
he didn't want people to be forced with
vaccines so why is it that uh the black
or otherwise social justice inclined
employees of netflix did not protest
that larry elder is a black man who was
you know honestly and forthrightly uh
saying what he believed in trying to
become the first black governor of
california why was that not a social
justice cause for these people why were
they not upset that reid hastings the
ceo of their company was lying about
larry elder these are all rhetorical
questions and i suppose you know the
answer um but the point here is that
god we just need to start mass
cancelling these things i've canceled a
couple of these services and it sucks
because it's like do you have to go back
to dvds like are we all gonna have to
have that big freaking giant dvd holder
beneath the tv that everyone used to
have we gotta go get one of those again
i'm gonna have to go to circuit city the
circuit city exist anymore that's where
i got one like back in 2002 and i had a
whole bunch of dvds in that thing that's
we're gonna have to go back to because
it's all they're pumping out crap there
are yes there is some stuff that's
pretty good but what but in essence what
he's saying is oh i have offended i have
allowed dave chappelle not i offended i
have allowed dave chappelle to offend a
couple people and that could cause real
world harm can someone point out to me
uh one person who's been physically
harmed because of dave chappelle
because of a joke that dave chappelle
said gender is a fact by the way it is a
fact i guarantee you it's a fact as i've
told you guys we are in the middle of
surrogacy when they take the sperm and
they take the egg they put them together
within two or three days with genetic
testing they tell you whether it's a
male or a female so either my doctor is
a complete crackpot nut bag racist
buffoon
or gender is real uh talley from local
says we all knew chappelle was going to
be taken off netflix since his first
special because the woke left wants
humor so sanitized funny is now
offensive yeah it's true it doesn't even
matter if you think what he's saying is
funny it actually does it it's like you
know some people like some comedians
some people like other comedians right
like that's just how it is but the point
is comedians especially in a healthy
society a comedian must be allowed to
say what they think without feeling like
they're going to be destroyed after now
that does not mean people cannot push
back of course all of these employees
they're allowed to you're allowed as a
as a employee to write a letter to your
superior and say you know that that
actually did bother me or whatever but
right now they're protesting outside of
the building it's like netflix reed
hastings other guy fire all these people
just fire them and go about making the
best programming you can but these
people have literally had their
testicles chopped off and they are being
held by a radical trans activist outside
of the netflix building there's some
imagery for you that probably offended
somebody although cutting your testicles
off is very in these days that's like
the new thing
that's like the thing now for these
people right
all right we got one more for you so
look we're getting all this vaccine
mandate stuff and if you turn on any
news channel there's no debate
about whether we should have mandates or
not there's very little debate about
whether we should have uh vaccines or
not you know whether your health and
your age and your the foods that you eat
and the medicines and supplements that
you take whether any of those things
should affect whether you need to take
the vaccine or not it's all just take
take take take every channel is just
take the vaccine mandates are good
there's almost no pushback we have
ridiculous civil rights lawyers like
gloria allred who i debated a couple
weeks ago if you haven't seen it it's on
our youtube channel who are saying this
is not about rights i mean we're just
not even debating the basic things that
used to be like absolute truths that
civil rights matter individual rights
matter
and if you wonder why if you've been
sitting there going you know something
doesn't seem right to me why is it that
these shows every cbs and nbc and
abc show they all keep pushing these
vaccines well this is just spectacular
who did this i want to credit them
properly because it's actually just
wonderful at underscore whitney webb two
bees
tweeted out this video it's a
compilation from some of your favorite
uh news programs take a look good
morning america is brought to you by
pfizer cbs healthwatch sponsored by
pfizer anderson cooper 360.
brought to you by pfizer abc news
nightlife
brought to you by pfizer making a
difference
brought to you by pfizer cnn tonight
brought to you by pfizer early start
brought to you by pfizer friday night on
aaron burnett out front brought to you
by pfizer this week with george
stephanopoulos is brought to you by
pfizer this weather report brought to
you by pfizer today's countdown to the
royal wedding is brought to you by
pfizer and now a cbs sports update
brought to you by pfizer meet the press
data download brought to you by pfizer
this portion of cbs this morning
sponsored by pfizer on how to find the
hidden sugars in the american family
diet sponsored by pfizer
must i add anything else
i'm dave rubin this has been the reuben
report
not brought to you
by pfizer
you